well it's a biggest modernizing speech
that David Cameron has made in years and
he'd probably since he became prime
minister it was a big attempt to
reposition the Tory party one of the
traditional Tory articles of faith if
you like has been that you know if you
work hard you can put yourself up by
your bootstraps and of everyone you know
if you work hard you get on this speech
was saying but there are too many people
in our society we've announced it's not
true here we would hence the warning
about the ethnic minority candidates for
jobs you're not getting interviewed
their names don't sound right so I mean
there was a big effort by Cameron's can
try and reposition the Tories to say
look we understand that opportunity
doesn't actually mean opportunity for
everybody at the moment well I thought
David Cameron's conference speech was
one of the most relaxed speech as I've
seen him given I thought it was the
clearest actually about what he stands
for what he believes as a conservative
and why he thinks that conservatism is
right for Britain he ran through a range
of social reforms that he wants to see
accomplished by the time he stands down
as Conservative leader and I think
actually accidentally saying that he
wasn't going to fight the 2020 election
as Tory leader was one of the best
things David Cameron could have dunks it
set himself a deadline by which he needs
to accomplish a legacy and he's clearly
sat down and thought what do I want to
do in a way that I don't think he did
before and that really really helped for
his confidence
I mean the most important message was
this message about real equality the
word of quality in the Tory party is not
it's not used that often and the fact
the Cameron chose to talk in this way I
think is quite a striking moment he was
basically saying but opportunity doesn't
act me an opportunity for too many
people and I think it's interesting to
see what he does on this discrimination
agenda but he was outlining I think his
most important messages were on social
reform I was also really struck by the
way that he talked about gay marriage
about aids spending and he expected the
conference to applaud him when he talked
about those things and they did he's won
their hearts as Tuohy leader in a way
that he hadn't in the previous
Parliament because he's won a surprise
majority in an election and they have to
respect that
I think there was some optically good
phrases like the turnaround decade he
used in his conclusion to talk about
frickin growing again and also he talked
about gender equality but then paraded
his wife at the end but I think that's
something that most party leaders and
got doing
the reception in the hall was very good
David Cameron got a number of standing
ovations and I was really struck by the
way they applauded him quite
enthusiastically on policies that
weren't popular when he introduced them
such as gay marriage and development
spending I mean they liked it I mean I
think Cameron was noticeably relaxed I
mean he had them he won them over
talking about the election and winning a
majority and I think you had that sense
in the halls oh this is the first time
we seen Cameron address the conference
hall as a majority winning Tory Prime
Minister and you could sense that that
shift in mood back I think it also bit
they will favor preparing to clean I was
quite struck by how warmly very planned
to clamp him on the real equality stuff
on his morning but the prison system
isn't working and I mean it was also
notable that when he mentioned Boris
Johnson where I started to get a
standing ovation from the hall which
capped off a very good conference week
for him
while it was quite as Barbara a
performance as as Boris Johnson's
yesterday but I mean I mean get the
leaner speech and that obviously makes
it the most significant speech of a
conference and it is by far the longest
and the chunk yes I think David Cameron
speech was a very good speech there were
other very good speeches too they Boris
Thompson speech was very very good and
George Osborne speech was good as well
but because they've a Cameron has said
that he's not standing again in 2020
hours to leader it doesn't there's not a
sort of direct comparison in the way
George Osborne and Boris Johnson are
being compared with one another because
they're competing for the future Tory
leadership they're not competing with
David Cameron or trying to undermine him